the jurgen experience i have been
hearing some american stereotypes my
scottish friend
and some ecuadorian friends and they're
like they make me go like oh no
so like we can't see it we're in the
forest you know you can't see the trees
number one yes americans like to wear
free bank t-shirts free bank t-shirts
that's stuff mbna you'll see no other
country
would you promote a bank just because
they gave you a free shirt
start looking around you'll see it
here's another one americans love
to comment on the beauty of a sunset
while you're watching it
nobody else does that everyone's
watching it man it's beautiful
and then they go yeah we know dude
american
shut up and enjoy it here's the last one
americans rush in to assist in a
situation that they have no experience
with
they'll see a bird hurt on the beach and
like get it in a box
we have to take it it's like do you know
anything about this
like sort of how bert moved tom's arm
when he broke it
yeah absolutely he touched it did he
really he was like let me move it picked
it up and put it over there probably
[ __ ] it up for life
oh jelly legs jelly like squirrel
dude it didn't make sense he just came
down he didn't even like
it wasn't like you see nba players they
come down yeah
like like conor mcgregor stepped wrong
you see it snapped no that's not what
happened
whatever segura starts to jump
and then it was like he's cursed by a
witch and she goes
it just went jump there was no impact
no he blew out his patella tendon he
blew out everything
everything like yeah what is that broke
when he landed on his arm and the legs
everything broke yeah well what happened
was
apparently he thinks he [ __ ] it up the
day before because he was
jumping in his office they were trying
to touch the ceiling
in the office like like this yeah trying
to touch the ceiling and he felt
something weird in his knee
but he didn't think too much of it and
then the next day
they were playing basketball they were
doing this dunk contest
and he dunked a couple of times and then
and then one time he really loaded up
and his patella tendon just blew out
so on the leap up his legs just gave way
blew apart wow yeah his knee just went
like that it's so
crazy looking yeah he doesn't yeah it's
always on the come
down he went on the way up mm-hmm
i heard a doctor say is that him
oh my god that's hilarious
that's great of course he's making
[ __ ] merch on it i got nobody cashes
in more than tom
hilarious he um he uh i heard a doctor
once a long time ago say
in your 40s is when you have you do
explosive movements and you don't have
explosive strength
and that's where you get in trouble
interesting still trying to make ski
jumps
right you should have stopped at 31
right but
at 60 you're not trying to make those
jumps anymore that makes sense yeah
or you just keep lifting weights and
don't be a [ __ ] yeah you're an outlier
yeah yeah you just got to know what your
body's capable of doing and the only way
you know is to make it do a lot of [ __ ]
so you know what it could do all the
time most people just stop
that's what happens it's the grind it's
all about the grind like most people
like to get to a point that i don't want
to lift any more weights
i'm just going to get on this elliptical
machine listen to a book just go buster
douglas
yeah just be like fatten up and just
fatten up lay back
that happens a lot of fighters ricky
hatton got huge
really oh my god he got huge nfl players
he might have lost weight now but
he got real big a lot of guys get real
big when they just they just don't want
to
do anything anymore i get it they don't
want to be yeah i get it yeah and
you form a habit of that then you just
stay in it catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience